excitement and relief as the large
hadron collider subsystems were back
into action setting a new world record
colliding its first protons again after
three years of upgrades faster than ever
before dream team physicists and
engineers have been planning this part
of the experiment for 15 years
we just had collisions at an
unprecedented energy 13.6 tera electron
valve and this opens a new era of
exploration at cern a new chapter run
three of the large hadron collider will
give us collisions at
higher energy than before and also an
amount of data equivalent to the total
amount of data recorded
in the previous two runs and this of
course will increase our opportunities
for discovery or for understanding the
fundamental laws of the universe
this particle accelerator runs deep
below the swiss alps sending high
intensity beams through a 27 kilometer
tunnel and smashing them together it
takes thousands of magnets to create a
stable beam squeeze it thinner than a
human hair and guide them round the ring
and these are the results
it's been 10 years since the scientists
here discovered the higgs boson or god
particle which helped explain why mata
takes on mass to form stars and planets
but it only opened up more questions
the higgs boson of course is was kind of
a holy grail to find because we knew it
was there and finally we
managed to find it and
now there is a lot of work going on
to study it yeah it's a little bit like
you discover a new cave in a mountain
then you take a lot of time in order to
explore the cave and to understand how
this cave goes if there are paintings if
there are no paintings
physicists hope it will reveal the
secrets of dark matter that make up 85
of our universe but does not absorb
reflect or emit light
the data which is open to the public for
analysis is streaming in
already scientists have discovered three
new exotic quarks the tiniest particles
ever found they exist for just a hundred
thousandth of a billionth of a billionth
of a second and could give us answers
about the origins of the universe and
its fate
charlie angela al jazeera